Matthews in Florida hey Matthew how are
you I'm great
how's it going better than I deserve
what's up okay so I read in your book
that we should do a health savings
account or that that's a good option and
I just want to see if it's a good option
for me in my current situation so right
now I have a family of five three kids
so I seen three kids and I'm I'm
self-employed so I I currently have Blue
Cross Blue Shield like health insurance
for the whole family it's $1400 a month
so the health savings account would be
fourteen sixty three sixty three more
dollars a month through Blue Cross Blue
Shield why and I don't make sense does
that include a savings contribution I'm
not sure it would be a the only
difference between the two things you'd
be a six thousand dollar maximum
out-of-pocket for the health savings
account one and eighty two hundred
dollar max out-of-pocket for the normal
one that I currently have my financial
advisor said it would save me
7k twenty one hundred and taxes maximum
contribution of seven thousand what are
you saying yeah but is this is the seven
thousand built into the 1463 it must be
hears woke a what's your current
deductible on your current my current
deductible is I believe sixty five
hundred but within maximum out-of-pocket
of eighty three hundred so you're
running a high deductible anyway yeah
exactly
because usually an HSA is a higher
deductible but is cheaper premium in
most cases weird yeah this one's a lower
deductible but a higher premium well
you're carrying a very high deductible
yeah that for the health savings account
alone it would be a six thousand dollar
deductible I know but I'm saying and you
said yours is sixty-five hundred on your
current plan right yes yes yeah which
most people have like a thousand really
yeah
which would probably cost you 1800 bucks
the way they're charging you there Thank
You Obamacare you're man you are getting
hammered
I got ya I'm getting hammered I'm hoping
something happens with this soon but I'm
used to it I guess I'm used to it used
to well if you still have that the only
purpose of the health savings account do
you still have debt now we're on step
four five and six and we do about 250 a
year okay well you can do the HSA but
the only reason to do it then is to
create the savings account option and
you don't need to do that necessarily
it's not that big a deal I mean
obviously if you if you don't do that
you cannot contribute to $7,000 right if
you do do it you can contribute the
$7,000 which in your tax bracket will
save you more than $2,000 on taxes
because you're a parent you're in a 40%
bracket I don't know how he's
calculating that so probably more like
3,500 in taxes or 3,000 but anyway
somewhere it's not a big difference
bottom line is 763 dollars a month extra
is not your anything except you've
lowered your out-of-pocket stop-loss
you've lowered your deductible and
you've lowered your stop-loss right
which you don't need to do so you
recommend to not do it to help things
count in the situation in your situation
I would not I wouldn't matter I would
keep the higher deductible the slightly
higher out-of-pocket the slightly lower
monthly monthly and then I would just do
my investing somewhere else the only
reason to do this is to lower your risk
you can handle the risk it's not that
much different and the only reason to do
this the only other reason to do it
would be to get the $7000 into the
health savings account I wouldn't do all
this for that yeah I'll pass it's a very
unusual situation you're in though the
reason is your income so high you were
willing to take on an unusual health
policy which is a super high deductible
and that's that's what's that's what's
change the numbers here but hey you know
normally what it would be is you would
be like with a thousand dollar
deductible and you'd have like a two
thousand dollar premium
but if you went with a higher deductible
HSA plan you'd have like a fourteen
hundred and sixty-three dollar premium
that would be the normal comparison with
a typical person calling me that's what
the book was addressing in Matthew hey
thanks for the call